hey if you want basting you like Till's
you're gonna love my best deals
check out my cyber monday dark where but
mega deals this Cyber Monday I give you
all the best dark with mega deals or my
name isn't Brian Anderson
check out these mega deals by three
missing yachts get the fourth one for
half price
those aren't missing anymore you found
them sits briefly on Ferraris for price
of five and a half Ferraris how briefly
don't where they ask the guy to pissed
off my uncle the gerbil from the urban
legend yes is he same gerbil who boy he
could talk laptop sandwich hahaha that
is just funny way of saying three
stacked laptops full of personal info
dinner with Tony Danza for just the
price of Tony danza's dinner with dr.
Crowley back safe and sound just three
million dollars in unmarked bills
Kylie misses you where your daughter is
a daughter's priceless knock down to has
a price how do the diaries do you know
here by a Gary by two guards these guys
think Gary got into trouble with the
wrong people's nothing for sale hey do
you like swords buy now and get a free
swords one per Gary gun shop now and
tell them Brian Anderson sent you
whereas website for deals just ask any
co-worker who recently told you about
Bitcoin he
show you
[Applause]